all right let's hear from a few more
people via discord at davidpakman.com
discord we'll go next to jen from
providence jen you're on the air
hey can you hear me yes i can hi uh
we've actually spoken a couple of times
before
uh i live on the border beautiful oh yes
you're right right right and did you
work in massachusetts was it
yeah i'll work in mass shop and mass but
then you live in providence you go back
and forth got it and uh
you see my super chats all the time my
screen name's fair queen oh okay it's
beautiful
yeah so i actually wanted to talk to you
about the super chat i did earlier to
get your opinion on it
uh it was on a wjar your local station
too so you'll probably end up seeing it
um there's a grocery store chain in the
northwest called fred meyers
okay they lost power and they had a lot
of food waste
so they were actually instructing their
employees to destroy as much as they
could
so the homeless wouldn't go and take the
food
people started taking some anyway and
also people running local food banks
because their supplies are so
short yes uh the guy actually had a
dozen
uh portland police officers go and stand
guard and threaten people
to like not be able to take any of this
food yeah
um it's gotten that bad with the
corporatism and the
girl who did the article said this was a
guy who also refused to donate
their old computers to local schools
i mean listen in the past if the story
is as you describe it and nothing else
and of course i'm just going by what
you're telling me
it sounds absolutely depraved and
disgusting now we've covered in the past
how
many grocery stores are hesitant to
donate
food that is maybe on the verge of
expiration to food banks because of
concerns about liability
which are not their fault and even that
i sort of take issue with like can't we
figure out some way
of making sure that that we can do that
because food wastage is such an
issue and we want to deal with that
liability it doesn't sound
at all from what you're telling me like
that's what's at issue here and
if if it's as you describe and again i
don't know um
it's disgusting yeah that's why you have
better sources than i do so i was hoping
that maybe you could do a little
research
and before tonight's show maybe look
into that well you know
the uh the show has already been the
show has been produced for today but i
will look into it
i do want to know more about it it
sounds crazy yeah and uh real quick
uh so all this stuff that they're saying
about the solar panels being covered in
snow and whatnot they're trying to blame
green energy
yeah my fiance is union electrician and
build solar farms as part of his job
they these panels are specially equipped
to not allow snow to stay built up on
them
right they're put at a specific angle
they're coated with special uh
like kind of like a waxy kind of thing
almost yep so
that is not the problem oh we're not
winterized or whatever
i mean i grew up in louisiana if you get
a dusting of snow it's the apocalypse
right but yeah still they cannot
blame these solar panels because they
are so well engineered to handle this
yeah the solar panel piece i'm less
familiar with i know that the
that it is that with when it comes to
the wind turbines
they simply haven't made the changes to
them that you can make in order to make
them
uh impervious to the cold weather like
they've done in montana and wyoming and
wisconsin and so many other places
you want to hear something funny sure uh
they set
up a couple of wind turbines in one of
the nearby towns of johnston rhode
island
and there were people living in this
apartment complex that complained it was
going to
blow the smell of the city landfill
towards their apartment complex
oh boy i can't imagine that that's the
case given the at the elevation the the
height at which you put the wind
turbines
i've never heard that even alleged
before well just everybody was sharing
the clip from futurama him saying
windmills do not work that way
right but yeah i'm actually thinking it
was going to blow the smell other than
the wind moving the turbine i hadn't
heard that but i will check it out
all right thank you so much david uh you
know you keep seeing my super chats i
watch the show every day
all right jen from providence great to
hear from you very much appreciate that